nothing the claim author of the smartest
guys in the room out in paperback since
the fall of 2004 why did you participate
in the documentary on Enron well Alex
came to us in the early winter of 2004
Alex give me the film maker and
expressed an interest in making some
sort of film out of the book whether it
was a documentary a feature film and
frankly at that time and Ron had kind of
faded from the public consciousness I
think there was this belief that the
corporate scandals like Enron were this
natural reaction to the aftermath of the
bull market and now it was all over and
onward and upward and so people weren't
exactly beating down our door to come
and make it make a movie out of our book
and not only was Alex interested but he
had read the book and gotten out of it
what we hoped people got out of reading
the book which is that it's really a
story about people and not a story about
numbers so you don't need to make a film
that is explains all these complicated
transactions and run did you can make a
film that explains human weakness and
human frailties and and go a long way to
explaining what happened to Dan Ron I
have in my hands from March 5th 2001 by
Bethany MacLaine it starts out like this
in the Hollywood parlance the it girl is
someone who commands the spotlight at
any given moment you know like Jennifer
Lopez or Kate Hudson Wall Street is far
less glitzy but there's still such a
thing as a its stock right now that
title belongs to Enron the Houston
energy giant what did this start I'm not
sure it's so much started anything I
think I have said well this story began
this chain of events that led to Enron's
unraveling I think I'm more picked up on
a skepticism that was growing under the
surface about Enron and expressed that
and in the story I'm uncomfortable as
seeing that story is an actor in events
I see it as more an observation on a on
a skepticism that was growing about
Enron boat in the business community and
among investors and so I'm not sure if
that story hadn't been published that
history would have been changed
I think the skepticism was there
regardless of whether I expressed it or
not maybe it accelerated something there
was fortune magazine March 5th again
2001 what was known at that time what
were the feelings in the air about Enron
was interesting because Enron was really
as the lead into that story expresses it
was one of those companies that could do
no wrong the stock had gone up I think
90% in the year 2000 every Wall Street
analyst with the exception of one who
followed the company stock was telling
investors to buy it everybody who talked
about Enron said well this is a company
that's revolutionizing business and
that's what people would say at first
when I started talking to them but
underneath that not with everybody but
with a few people there was this sort of
vein of fear and people were unwilling
to say anything on the record but people
would say things to me like well their
their meetings our revival meetings or
the California energy crisis was going
on at the time this company is making a
lot of money or losing a lot of money in
California but they'll hide it somehow
and Ron always does you were based where
in 2001 I was in New York how long had
you lived here I had lived here since
let's see early 92 mid 92 what was the
reason he came here in the first place
I came to New York to work as an
investment banking analyst so a lot of
the big Wall Street firms hire people
right out of college and you work there
supposedly for two years and you
basically work 80 hours a week plus and
you crunch lots of numbers and learn how
to read balance sheets and then maybe
you go on to go to business school and
you come back as a senior investment
banker what company did you work for I
worked for Goldman Sachs and why did you
take that job honestly I really I had no
idea what I was getting into I'd love to
say I had some well thought out plan for
what Investment Banking was and how it
could further my career but the simple
truth of the matter was I was a math
major in college and fit my senior year
without much of an idea what I was going
to do afterwards and found that Wall
Street firms were pretty interested in
me given given my math background and I
ended up being recruited by a couple of
them and I thought a practical
application of my math skills that's not
so bad they're going to pay me I can
live in New York I'll do that so goldman
sachs and back you graduate Williams
College where's that located it's
located in Williamstown Massachusetts
back to him being Minnesota how long did
you live there I lived in Hibbing from
the time I was five until I was eight
eighteen seventeen when I left for
college and what were your parents
what's their profession my dad was a
doctor and my mom was a homemaker
they still along they are still alive
they no longer live in Hibbing however
the winter is 70 below zero got to be
too much for them and so along the route
there did you ever think you were going
to work at Goldman Sachs or did you ever
think you're going to write for Fortune
magazine I would have had no idea what
Goldman Sachs was Hibbing as a mining
town up in northern Minnesota so most of
what what what's a firm like Goldman
Sachs is just not part of the the
parlance of a town like Hibbing so no
and while I always had an interest in
writing I think my parents were
scientists my mom was a scientist as
well and I think if I'd had any plan to
find plan for what I wanted to do when I
grew up it would have been something in
science what did you learn about this
world of money when you worked at
Goldman Sachs I learned a lot actually
working there and it was tough it was it
was it's a hard place to work especially
if you're not if you don't know what
you're getting into and you don't know
what corporate America is going to be
like but I learned I learned to make
sense of a company's financial
statements and to figure out how the way
a company made money was translated into
figures on a balance sheet or how it
wasn't in some cases and I think I
learned to that corporate executives are
people to with with with weaknesses just
like the rest of us and so by the time I
got to fortune I wasn't in off people
anymore and I think that that helped me
in my career as a reporter and back to
that story from March 5th you write the
third paragraph in but for all the
attention that's lavished on Enron the
company remains largely impenetrable to
outsiders as even some of its admirers
are quick to admit start with a pretty
straightforward question how exactly
does Enron make its money who was asking
that question besides you back then well
the person who first told me to take it
closer look at Enron was a guy named Jim
Janus
who is a short seller meaning that he's
looking for stocks that are going to
decline in value you won't find his name
anywhere in that story because he was an
off-the-record source at the time
meaning that he gave me a tip but I
couldn't quote him or use information
that came from him unless I corroborated
elsewhere but he told me to take a
closer look at Enron's financial
statements and because I had because I
had a at least a basic knowledge of
Finance I could feel pretty comfortable
flipping open and Ron's documents and
going through them and if I couldn't
figure out how the company made money
not that I know know everything I'm an
expert by any means but I I know I know
and I know enough that if something
doesn't make sense to me then there are
more questions to be asked so the story
you suggest that the Enron officials
wouldn't give the information for
competitive reasons you have that in
quotes and the numbers at Enron does
present are often extremely complicated
even quantitatively meited Wall
Streeters who scrutinized the company
for a living think so quote if you
figure it out let me know laughs credit
analyst Todd shipment at S&P when you
did that how old would you you've been
then I was thirty at the time how do you
feel what's it feel like what kind of
responsibility is if your work writing
for Fortune magazine and you're dealing
in this town with money and the market
and a big company called Enron I'm not
sure I thought about it at the time I
sure I did on some level my friends tell
me now that I was terrified as I was
writing about this and completely
stressed out and they remember me just
being in a totally panic state during
during this period I guess it's one of
those things that you tend it we tend to
repress the memory somehow because I
remember getting getting interested in
thinking well well this is a really
interesting question this company has
this high-flying stock price and it's a
very expensive stock and yet nobody
seems to know how exactly the company
the company makes its money and how
strange is that
and there's normally companies that are
that are that impenetrable trade at
something of a discount because people
don't like that you can't figure it out
yet here was Enron trading trading at a
premium and it just seemed like an
intellectually interesting question and
I guess by the time I was at the point
of maybe if I'd paused at the beginning
and said
oh this might be really scary to
actually deal with all of this maybe I
would have stopped but I'm not sure I'm
not sure I asked that question of myself
until it was too late in any as anybody
else written much like this about Enron
back in those days um no there had been
one piece that ran in The Wall Street
Journal not in the Wall Street Journal
I'm sorry in a local Dow Jones paper
earlier that fall that looked at Enron
as well as other energy trading
companies and questioned an aspect of
their accounting but apart from that
most of the press surrounding Enron was
was glowing at that time did you try to
talk with Enron officials oh I did of
course because one of the key
responsibilities of a reporter is before
you publish anything you have to give
the subject of your story the chance to
respond so I called Enron to get to get
their reaction to some of the questions
I was asking here's a quote in your
story people who raise questions are
people who have not gone through our
business in detail who wanted to throw
rocks at us says skilling indeed Enron
dismisses criticisms as ignorance or as
sour grapes on the part of analysts who
failed to win its investment banking
business the last word in that so you
talked to mr. skilling I did I did I
called Enron and they put me on the
phone with with Jeff Skilling who had
very little time when I spoke to him and
became became very irate because he
thought I hadn't taken the time to
understand his business and said that if
I had been that it was unethical of me
to raise questions without having fully
taken the time to understand the
business and that's actually a scary
thing to be told as a reporter because
that can be right you know no matter how
much time you've spent trying to figure
something out that's always possible
that you haven't spent enough time and
that you are getting it wrong and that
you really you really don't understand
as much as you should so it was it was
it was a frightening conversation what's
the status of Jeff Skilling right now he
and Ken he's was indicted for his role
and what the government dubbed the end
round fraud and is awaiting criminal
trial in early 2006 you write a lot
about him in the book yes we do write a
lot about him in the book what's
happened to him
I think that by the way let me start
with what was his job at Enron in 2001
Jeff was the see Jeff was the president
and chief operating officer of Enron
from 1996 on and then he became the
company's CEO in early 2001 and after
just six months of serving as CEO he
abruptly quit in August of 2001 and that
really helped accelerate the company
slide into bankruptcy because it was so
unusual for a chief executive officer to
just quit after that short an amount of
time that that all sorts of all sorts of
focus went to Enron so what what
happened to him in this last four years
well I think it's not been a very
pleasant four years for Jeff Skilling he
was the only Enron executive to testify
in front of Congress in the wake of the
company's collapse and he basically
denied any responsibility or any
knowledge of the events that brought the
company down and he characterized it as
a run on the bank I think it's pretty
clear from the government's indictment
that of him that they don't they don't
believe that story but it you know it's
interesting because I think I think Jeff
does believe that story I think self
delusion is a really important component
of the Enron story and I think many of
the top executives who who worked there
believed very strongly in the company
because they wanted to believe very
strongly in the company and I think in
the wake of the company's bankruptcy
some of them have dug in even more into
into that point of view Jeff I think he
was picked up in New York for a episode
where he where he was supposedly costing
people on the street and accusing them
of being FBI agents while while he was
drinking and his lawyers have sort of
denied that version of events but that's
what the New York City police told told
people at the time and it it it it just
he's he's something of a tragic figure I
think where does he live now lives in
Houston well I want to run just a little
bit of the trailers that we can't run
much of the documentary even though some
of the footage comes from c-span they
paid us for the footage and there's a
lot of it in there and a lot of our
audience saw the original hearing
schools we've covered almost all of it
but let's just run a little bit of this
so people get a sense of what the
documentaries do
with including your involvement by the
way how much time did you personally
spend on the documentary how many hours
did you were you interviewed I think I
was interviewed for probably two hours
and Peter and I my co-author Peter
Elkind and I helped Alex it with some of
the work on the documentary ideas of who
to talk to where to get information but
the documentary itself is really the
work of Alex Gibney and his crew of
people because in the end putting
together a documentary is a pretty
different process than writing a book
and Alex Gibney is the same man who did
the trials of Henry Kissinger yes did he
bring an attitude to the documentary I
don't think so I think he whatever
attitude he brought to it was probably
shaped by our book which does have a
strong point of view to it and that
point of view I guess is that not
necessarily we would never apply on
anybody's criminal guilt in advance of
their trial but the point of view in the
book is that the top executives of Enron
are ethically guilty for what for what
happened at Enron and excuses like I
didn't know it was one of my underlings
who did it just don't fly review what
has happened to Enron as a company how
much money has been lost and what does
the stock holders lose and all this at
the peak of Enron's power it had a
market capitalization of seventy billion
dollars and that's just gone the equity
and the company has been totally wiped
out after a three-year very arduous
complicated bankruptcy procedure and
that was that was pretty much wound up
at the end of last year I think the last
estimate I heard was that creditors were
supposed to get maybe 20 cents on the
dollar which kind of shows you that
there really wasn't much left at the end
of it all and a couple of pieces of
Enron survived it owned a utility out in
Washington called Portland general and
that utility still operates and run
owned pipelines and those have been sold
off to other investors and they owned a
bunch of assets around the world
including this one in the film that was
built in Deb ball India and that's going
to be spun off into a separate publicly
traded company but the sort of Enron of
myth of the Enron that that existed in
the 1990s for all intents and purposes
doesn't exist anymore one of the things
you often never see after one of these
things
if it lost seventy billion dollars in
value who lost that 70 billion did
somebody physically lose that kind of
money and who would it be
well people lost it all the way as the
stock fell so but a lot of investors in
Enron stock from pension funds to big
mutual funds who owned shares and often
those big mutual funds and pension funds
owned shares on behalf of individual
investors there were sophisticated hedge
funds who came in and thought they were
buying a bargain as the stock fell and
ended up losing losing a lot of money
employee has lost a great deal of money
because a lot of their 401k plans were
invested in run stock so I think the the
real losers in the in the Enron
bankruptcy were the employees and
individual investors also the people
that worked there some of them have pled
guilty already and all that how much of
that their money can they keep they've
gotten to keep very little most of the
people who have pled guilty have had to
forfeit everything that they have
what about mr. Fastow mr. Fastow had to
forfeit 23 million dollars I believe is
the number and it seemed low in light of
the money that he took out of the
company but I'd actually done a little
bit of homework into that after after
writing the book and I think he had
spent most of the other money on legal
fees so I think the government has been
pretty aggressive about taking
everything that's left what about
somebody Ken Lay today he's waiting for
trial and January trial in Jenni where
does he have money well he says in the
film that he was left with very little
that he and his wife were left with only
20 million dollars in the wake of
Enron's collapse and only 1 million of
that in liquid assets so I mean poor
poor Ken Lay having to learn to live
with only 20 million dollars when I saw
the documentary the crowd moaned and
groaned at that point did where did that
video come from do you remember when he
said he that he only had 20 million left
I don't it was from a press conference
that he gave after his indictment but I
don't recall exactly whose footage that
was but it was it was a press conference
after that he held after he was indicted
legally at this point legally at this
point until until and until or unless he
is he has found guilty it's it's his
money
and what is the documentary done
up to this moment for you and your book
it's made people a lot it's it's it's
really interest in our book which has
been great because you spend a couple
years of your life working on a book
like this and so to have people
interested in it again I think a lot of
people go to see the film and they say
that's great now I now stand something
about Enron and then there's a small
group of people who go to see the film
and say wow now I want to know more let
me go read the book so how much of your
life revolved around this story and for
how long
well I guess I published my first orient
and run in early 2001 as we've discussed
and then something I still fought myself
or I put it on the back burner until the
fall of 2001 when the company went
bankrupt and I guess the next probably
two years I worked on Enron pretty much
non-stop I came back to my job at
fortune in the fall of 2003 and have
written a number of other other stories
but with the documentary and Ron has
become part of my life again
what does fortune magazine owned by Time
Warner what is fortune magazine say to
somebody like you in the middle of all
this take all the time you want do they
have any rights to the things you're
writing for their own magazine well we
structured our we structured our deal
with fortune in a kind of interesting
way I think a lot of journalists who
write a book just take a leave from the
publication that they work for and then
they're just off on their own
so we set our deal up where we actually
stayed on staff at fortune didn't work
on anything but the book but fortune
gave us gave us the time to do that do
they take stories from you as that time
goes and put it in fortune they really
didn't we did a few separate stories for
the magazine as news on Enron would
break but I think it was pretty much
understood that we were focusing on the
book for that period of time I want to
go back to your original story and read
this line Enron vehemently disagrees
with any characterization of its
business as black box like or better
said black box like what does that mean
one of the central contentions in this
story was that Enron was something of a
black box which isn't necessarily a bad
thing there are a lot of firms today
that are something of a black box
because they're financially very
complicated but firms like that such as
Wall Street firms
normally their stock price is pretty
cheap relative to their earnings because
investors look at the company and say I
can't tell how they're making money I
don't know if they're going to make the
same amount of money next year as they
did this year I can't see inside this
company it's a black box so there's a
discount that comes with that Enron's
business was extremely complex in that
in that same fashion and but they didn't
want to be known in that way because
that would have lowered their stock
price and Enron was a company that was
very obsessed with its stock price and
if its stock price was going to command
if its stock was going to command a
premium price it had to be known as a
company that people could predict its
earnings you say fast out who points out
that Enron has 1217 trading books for
different commodities says quote we
don't want anyone to know what's on
those books we don't want to tell anyone
where we're making money now why would
then stock traders or people in places
like Goldman Sachs buy this whole thing
why would they agree I mean when they
looked at it why they say this is they
won't tell us what they're doing why
shouldn't they what should they take a
chance with it I think two reasons
because every year and Ron the 1990s
were a time about where the thing that
was prized more than anything in a
company was the ability to deliver
consistent quarterly earnings growth
that met Wall Street as Wall Street's
estimates and Enron did quarter after
quarter they played that game magically
we now know that they were resorting to
all sorts of tricks in order to in order
to do that but at the time people said
look look at their track record we can
we can we can predict this and I think
the other thing that played into that
was this the title of our book is the
smartest guys in the room and the unrung
guys really had a reputation for being
smarter than other people and so
investors looked at this and said wait
you know we can just believe these guys
and they spit out the right numbers
quarter after quarter and why not and of
course an important component of that is
greed we all wanted the stock to go
higher right on top of that and Ron paid
Wall Street firms huge amounts of
investment banking fees and if you as a
Wall Street firm wanted Enron's
investment banking fees the analysts who
covered Enron stock had to tell
investors to buy that was the quid pro
quo that Enron demanded and so there was
very little incentive for
people who analyzed the company to look
too closely and say I don't like this at
this stage as a my gonna prison
um yes leaf asta Andy's wife has gone to
prison and I believe Ben Gleason who was
the company's treasurer has also begun
serving his five-year term a number of
people have been sentenced but they're
aware have been have been sentenced and
found guilty or pled guilty but they are
awaiting they're at the beginning of
their present sentence as a butt for a
test intern for their testimony you're
right I think that leaf ass now
originally got five months and ended up
getting a year she ended up getting a
year and what was the mechanism there
that gave her an extra few months I
think it's very complicated and the
Justice Department in effect used leaf a
stout to get Andy Fastow to plead guilty
and and there's you you can debate
there's something ugly about any kind of
prosecution right and there's certainly
something ugly about about this that
said from all the evidence I've seen
leaf esta was guilty she was implicated
in in the schemes Andy Fastow Andy
Fastow devised so the original deal that
was cut with the Justice Department was
Lee would only get five months so that
she could be out of jail by the time
Andy began serving his sentence and when
that agreement was posed to the judge
who was handling the case he said no way
her crimes are more serious than this
I'm not going to agree to that and so he
gave her stiffer sentence one of the
things that came through in the
documentary for me was watching it is
all of a sudden it looms large that
Enron put a lot of its businesses in
Andy fast outside businesses to hide the
debt mm-hmm how long did it take to find
that out in this process and explain it
I don't think anybody understood during
the course when Enron was a functioning
company that this is what was happening
and it's interesting because there were
disclosures and Enron's footnotes to its
financial statement which frankly very
few people bother reading a whole
subject unto itself don't you stop there
from it what do you explain more of it
companies have to file financial
statements with the Securities and
Exchange Commission where they're
required legally to disclose all sorts
of information and the footnotes to
those financial statements are often
very dense lots and lots of none
lots of words so in the footnote Stan
Ron's financial statements there are
these things called related party
transactions and it involved a couple of
entities that had been set up by Enron
that were run by its chief financial
officer Andy Fastow that did all their
business with the company now it's
extremely strange to have an outside
partnership doing all of its business
with with the company run by the company
CFO because who is the CFO whose
interest is the CFO serving is he
serving the interests of the outside
partnership or is he serving the
interests of the company but nobody
looked very closely at this disclosure
in Enron's financial statements until
the fall of 2001 you even though
interestingly enough I did and I asked
Andy Fastow about it but I did not end
up writing about this in my original
story that I published because Enron
said and it was true that its accounting
firm and its board of directors had
signed off on these arrangements and
while I was already cynical about some
things
I was not cynical about the role of
accountants and the role of a Board of
Directors and I thought if they've
signed off on it then I guess I must be
missing something and this must be okay
I was naive who's on the board of
directors at the time the top executives
of the company Ken Lay Jeff Skilling
some very high powered outside invest
outside investors and also the former
dean of the Stanford Business School and
there ain't political figures um there
was a Wendy Gramm who was phil gramm's
wife and who had run the Commodities
Futures Trading Commission right in the
middle your book and in the documentary
is Alan Greenspan going to Houston to
get the Enron public service award what
in the world why would the head of the
Federal Reserve and the Federal Reserve
Board go to Houston on behalf of a
company to get a public service award
and Ron was really great at doing things
like this and increasing its visibility
in Washington through prizes like this
and a guy like Alan Greenspan would have
thought oh here's this great company
down in Houston Texas that's being
celebrated for its inventiveness and
that's changing changing the world and
revolutionising markets and they're
going to offer me this this prize
commemorating me and it was just one
more example of how Enron was very
clever it burn
in its own image because of course the
association then between Enron and Alan
Greenspan at the time really enhance 10
rounds credibility but go back down in
Greenspan why would he even think about
it I mean what why would you can't
answer I can't answer a quest the
question for Greenspan is your money
involved in I don't believe there was I
think the money got donated to do it
charity but but I'm not sure about that
go back to the fine print mm-hmm why and
who does read the fine print I mean you
said you read a little bit didn't do
anything with it filed to the SEC the
Securities and Exchange Commission did
they read it the Securities and Exchange
Commission did not reread it one of the
darker parts of the un-- run story is
the failure of many people in government
to do their jobs as well and in that
list is you have to include the SEC
they're often after all in charge of
monitoring corporate America and they
had not reviewed Enron's financial
statements since 1997 I believe was last
year when the company went bankrupt in
the truth of the matter as the SEC has
just overburdened with work and so no
they had not read that disclosure
because they hadn't looked in your story
the original story you talk about Enron
having thirteen billion dollars with the
debt was that a lot and was at all no as
it turns out that was a fair amount of
debt for a company with its equity base
at the time but that was not all the
company actually at that time had about
thirty eight billion dollars of debt so
where was it hidden it was some it was
hidden in a variety of places some of it
was associated with these projects that
had done projects that had done to build
power plants around the world some of it
was in partnerships the company had set
off set up off its balance sheet where
it had then moved debt to these
partnerships other pieces of it was kind
of a piece of it were kind of disguised
in its financial statements they were
recorded as cash flow making the
company's operations look much healthier
but in substance these transactions were
loans and should have been thought of as
part of Enron's debt so it was stashed
in a variety of places
recently I books come out by Kurt I can
wall New York Times what did he do with
the Enron story that you didn't I think
Kurt's book and I should be careful
because I have a
actually read Kurt's book mainly because
I've been I've been just terribly busy
with with some other other stories
trying to trying to make my life be
about something other than Enron from
what I've been told of Kurt's book I
think he told the story in a very
different way than we did he told it in
a very chronological fashion whereas we
kind of stepped back and told it a story
that was based first on characters and
then about certain discrete episodes in
Enron's history and a comment people
have made to me about Kurt's book is
that he's probably perhaps less
judgmental about Ken Lay then than we
are and I don't know if Kurt would agree
with that statement or not a couple of
reviewers for example have written them
what do you say about Ken Lay I think
Ken Lay probably was clueless about a
lot of the Massah nations that took
place at Enron but I don't think and it
remains for a court to decide whether
he's criminally guilty but I think it is
very clear that he's ethically guilty I
don't understand how a CEO can take
hundreds of millions of dollars in a
competent compensation from a company
supposedly because of the great job
they're doing running that company and
then when things go bad say not me
I didn't no not my fault not my
responsibility that just to me is an
incredible shirking of responsibility
and I think if that sort of attitude is
allowed to stand it says something
pretty frightening about about corporate
America what's the relationship between
Ken Lay and George W Bush they were they
were buddies although Ken Lay was closer
with George Bush and senior than he was
with George Bush jr. but Enron was very
close to the Bush administration what
was the nickname that President Bush
near by and has that bothered or hurt in
any way President Bush's image in the
country because of his relationship on I
think it did initially there was a lot
of fir about this and a lot of I think
sort of the notion that this could be
you know Enron gate and I think some of
that has been diffused by the undeniable
fact that muscian ministration didn't
save and Ron as it was going down and if
this really were a political scandal
somebody in the Bush administration
would have would have tried to say save
the company I think some of that has
also been diffused by the aggressive
prosecution of the company
after after after its bankruptcy and I
think more of it has just been diffused
by events like Iraq totally outside of
Enron where some of the focus on
wrongdoing in corporate America has been
has been lifted and I'm not sure I'm not
sure that's necessarily it would have
been interesting had Enron continued to
exist what the relationship between
Enron and the Bush administration would
have brought because we are only a year
into into the Bush administration when
the company went bankrupt
he had a partner in this book Peter
Elkin who is he he has another senior
writer at fortune and he's based in
Dallas Texas he's a longtime
investigative reporter who worked for
Texas Monthly for a while one of the
things you notice if you see the
documentary is the person who's behind
it at least one of the people behind it
is somebody named Mark Cuban and it's
HDNet Gates Mark Cuban owns about Dallas
Mavericks and he was a very successful
businessman in the telecommunications
world he lives in Dallas I believe and
this story is out of Houston what can
you tell us about why Mark Cuban's
behind this probably not as much as Alex
or Mark Cuban can tell you but from the
way I've heard the story relayed Alex
submitted a proposal to Mark Cuban who
had made it known that he wanted to
finance independent movies and Alec said
it was the quickest green light he's
ever gotten on any project he's done I
think even though Marc's located in
Dallas you know he's in Texas and so he
sees the results of Enron every day and
I think also having been in the business
world he had an appreciation of the
story any idea how much you spent I
don't actually know but documentaries
are usually really low budget and I
think this one was no exception we're
not talking Hollywood blockbuster
dollars here so you're out of Williams
College since 1992 and which makes you
put you in your early 30s what is what
do you say as you're going what do you
saying to yourself and your friends is
you going through this what's it say
about this country business anything
concluding I may be concluding as you
went along about all this I mean I
definitely become more cynical than I
would like to be about corporate America
and about whether people tell the truth
and about whether people live up to the
responsibilities that being a citizen
corporate citizen entails I think our
American system makes it possible for
people to make great sums of money be
they accountants lawyers members of
boards of directors corporate executives
and I'm not sure that the concurrent
measure at level of responsibility comes
with that
I think the corporate culture has been
corrupted by this get-rich-quick notion
make your quarterly earnings estimates
get the stock to go high or get your
options in the money and cash out and
you know who cares what happens next I'm
gone and I've made my money and I see
that I see that pretty frequently and I
think that's just such I think that's
really terrible not just because it's a
betrayal of responsibility but it's also
a betrayal of possibility because when
you look at what companies that really
do their job well can accomplish you
know look at what Bill Gates has done
with his foundation giving giving away
billions you know that's that that's
what that's what business kandi the
obviously Microsoft's business practices
yes some of its competitors would
complain about that but but but he's
taken the money he's made and at least
given given some of it back and when you
see that just being betrayed so that
people can put money in their own
pockets I think it's just really
disillusioning what happened you inside
fortune more or less interested in
writing stories or books I still try to
be driven by intellectual curiosity
people said to me after have said to me
frequently after the wake of the Enron
story well what's the next big story and
aren't you looking for the next big
story and of course there's a part of me
that would love to find another big
story but I wrote about Enron initially
not because I thought it was going to be
a big story not because I ever saw it
turning into a book or a documentary but
because I thought the company posed a
fascinating intellectual conundrum and I
think if you let your curiosity as a
journalist lead you places sometimes you
may end up wasting your time and you may
spend months writing about something
that's mostly interesting to you if not
not anybody else but I think other times
maybe your curiosity will lead you in it
in an interesting direction so I try to
be driven by that how has your life
changed in the last three four years it
hasn't changed that much I mean writing
is a solitary process
no I still work for fortune as a
journalist you know I still call it PR
people and say this is Bethany McLean
and people say Stephanie Daphne
they have MediConnect no not necessarily
no in some cases people do but not
always there a couple things before I
want to take you back to the very
beginning of the book but I also want
you to talk about Jeffrey's killings
conversation on the phone with the
analysts the conversation hearing what
was it the conversation you're referring
to took place in the spring of 2001 and
the pressure at this time inside an Iran
was really escalating because the stock
was beginning to slide well but I mean
he said your beefs been written my peace
had been written they'd been out there
for a while the questions around Enron
were beginning to swirl to the surface
and so the skepticism instead of being
buried under this layer of celebration
of all things Enron was sort of bubbling
up to the surface and the stock price
was sliding and because so many of these
partnerships Andy Fastow had set up they
were actually tied to the price of Enron
stock it was not just a problem for
executives riches that the stock price
was sliding it was actually a big
problem for the company as well and so
skeptical questions were all the more
troublesome as a result and this guy on
and Ron's first quarter conference call
companies always hold a conference call
with investors after they announce their
result a man named Richard Grubman who
was short and Ron stock meaning he was
betting it was going to decline asked
asked Enron if they could produce a
balance sheet with their with their
income statement and Jeff Skilling
called him an [ __ ] and what happened
that was the moment for a lot of people
when they said something is wrong here
because it is just so rare to have any
kind of executive publicly lose it like
that and especially the CEO of a fortune
500 company to have him publicly lose
his temper in that way is just just too
strange and it made everybody think
something's not right at this company
were you listening at the time I was not
I was not listening to that conference
call but it immediately began to fly
around all sorts of chat rooms and a
couple people transcribed the
conversation so I know I heard about it
that
explain to someone who's never been
involved in a conference call like this
how does it work it's normally the
company begins senior management begins
and they present their results and in
Enron's case they'd say things like this
is fabulous our business is so terrific
this is just another great quarter great
results for our investors and then
there's a Q&A period where people have
the opportunity to ask questions a lot
of those questions if they're asked by
say the Wall Street analysts who have by
ratings on the stock are questions that
are designed to give management a chance
to say something another favorable thing
about their business so they're there
they're puffed they're puffy questions
so you go back to your former life and
goldman sachs so somebody who might be
getting money from Enron at goldman
sachs to analyze or give them
consultants
consult with them could be on the
conference call asking questions that
would enhance the stock it's not the
same person usually because those would
be different divisions within and within
an investment banking firm but in
essence you're right yes that stopped it
supposedly has stopped in the wake of
Enron's collapse and some of the other
corporate frauds Eliot Spitzer cracked
down on this sleazy relationship between
Wall Street research and Wall Street
investment banks and imposed a one point
four billion dollar settlement on Wall
Street firms who are all now supposedly
keep their research completely separate
from their investment banking divisions
I think time will tell how well that
actually works in practice
so who published what Jeff Skilling said
very few people did at the time it ad I
named herb Greenberg who writes
generally skeptical pieces online
published the transcript of Jeff's
remarks um I think the Wall Street
Journal might have made note of it um
somewhere in an article but a lot of
people let it go it was one of those
things that unless you were watching and
run closely unless you were a Wall
Street person the press didn't make much
of it I think people who were investors
in Enron made a lot of it but if you go
back to your original story you raised
all this business of in the story about
not getting to the bottom of where the
money is and you know and the fact they
wouldn't publish all I do you think
people picked it up from your story the
idea of asking the question
I don't think Richard Grubman did I
think his skepticism about Enron had
started earlier but I mean I think the
story by my story by bringing to light
in a magazine like fortune which had
previously written very positive pieces
about Enron by publicly raising
questions like this I think it provided
a sort of validation for people who
wanted to ask questions that made them
think well maybe I'm not crazy because a
big part of what happened at Enron was
this intellectual intimidation if you if
you didn't go along with what Enron
wanted you to believe they'd say well
you just don't get it and everybody
wants to be thought of as smart we've
all been in the situation where you
don't really understand something but
you say you do because you don't want to
ask a stupid question and for a lot of
people it sounds hard to believe but for
a lot of people that's what happened
with Enron they didn't really understand
but they didn't want to ask so then I
think when something is published in
them in a major magazine like fortune
saying nobody gets this I think people
became a little bit I think people were
a little freer to voice their concerns
your paperback came out in the fall of
2004 when did your hardback come out he
came out the fall of 2003 how long did
it take you to write it it took about a
year and three quarters and how did you
and your co-author divide your interest
we really worked pretty closely Peter
was based in Texas and I was here in New
York we both spent a lot of reporting
time in Houston but we we did when we
had a key person to talk to would both
go to the interview but we divvied up
the list of people we wanted to talk to
and so we didn't we tried not to
tag-team people and we both shared all
the transcripts of our conversations
with each other and when it came time to
write the book we did a pretty
exhaustive outline and we just picked
chapters you know there were some
chapters were really fun to write and so
we both wanted to do them and then there
were some chapters that were really not
fun to write and so you know if you got
a fun one to take a not fun one who did
not talk to you and who talked to you
I've know unfortunately I can't say
because most of the people who talked to
us didn't talk on the record because
people were either already criminally
implicated or terrified of getting
dragged into the criminal the criminal
case and so people talk to us on the
condition of anonymity we talked on the
record
very few people one who did and who
spoke in the movie is a woman named
Amanda Martin who was a pretty senior
exec
and run sort of a part of a part of the
inner circle for a while and who is a
great observer of events the blonde
woman to know mm-hmm well-dressed how
did she make out after all this she made
out well she walked away with it from
Enron with a lot of money and people
have people's reaction to her in the
movie as a result has been has been
mixed I've always admired Amanda for one
being willing to come forward and say
things publicly and to for her ability
to reflect both on what happened at
Enron and on her own role in events as I
had said earlier the self the self
delusion at Enron was pretty remarkable
and I haven't met a lot of people who
have been willing to look back on their
role and say I did something wrong here
I learned from this I look back and see
this differently now than I did at the
time the epilogue to our book is
entitled isn't anybody sorry because the
reaction we got from most people was not
my fault not my responsibility I did
everything right I behaved perfectly one
of the gentlemen the movie who I guess
you'd say it was spotlighted critically
it was a man named Pei Liu PI they
kanpai Pei hey I yeah I will get it
right how much did he take away he sold
early and where does he live now he took
away over two hundred and fifty million
dollars from Enron it was more than
actually anybody made and he was an
interesting character instrumental in
building and Ron's early energy trading
operation kind of a ruthless strange
figure at Enron later Rand this doomed
effort and Ron had to expand into
providing energy services to to
companies and industries across America
he the story goes that he sold most of
his stock because he was divorcing his
wife in order to marry a stripper with
whom he'd had a child and one of the
things he was known for at Enron was his
obsession with with strippers we bought
a bunch of land in Colorado I think he
became the second-largest land of Honor
in Colorado the locals call his his
ranch mount pie
where does he live now I think he still
lives in Colorado I'd heard a rumor that
he sold it and moved to Hawaii but I'm
pretty sure he's still in Colorado
dieded yeah potential indictment there
are always rumors swirling around that
but one of the tricky things at Enron is
that and one of the reasons it's taken
so long to prosecute this case is that
criminal wrongdoing is often very
difficult to prove because it's very
rules based and one of the things Enron
was very skilled that was following the
letter of the law while totally
violating the spirit of the law so there
are a lot of people at Enron that you in
an ethical framework can blame for the
company's collapse but whether they're
criminally guilty is a much more
difficult call and to my mind not is
interesting one because in the end this
really is a story about about human
nature and I find that the more the more
interesting part of the story than sort
of the more narrow legalistic
definitions of criminal guilt now the
the documentary and your book start with
a story of about a man named cliff
Baxter why we began the book with a
story of cliff Baxter he's an Enron
executive who committed suicide in the
wake of the company's and in the wake of
the company's bankruptcy he was a very
senior Enron executive and was also one
of Jeff Skilling's close friends they
used to take cigarette breaks together
we began the book with his suicide
because we wanted to signal to readers
this was a story about people and this
was a story about about humans and I
think at the time when we are writing
our book there was this one a
presumption that Enron was a story about
numbers about complicated financial
transactions that you don't want to
understand even if you could and I think
there was another presumption which is
that these were just bad people doing
bad things down in Houston Texas and
none of us could ever do anything like
that and so I think the story we wanted
to tell was a story about people and a
story of people with very human fatal
flaws so that so that it becomes more of
a story that more of almost just more of
a tragic tale rather than this this
story of this limited story of bad
people and they're wrong how did you
find out specifically how cliff
Baxter killed himself I mean it's rather
detailed police files the police did the
police did a pretty serious
investigation into cliffs suicide
because there was so much for
surrounding Enron at the time that
people actually thought it might have
been a murder when did it happen and how
did it happen it happened in early 2002
right after the company's bankruptcy and
he shot himself and there was this this
this belief that well it must have been
murder he must have been silenced to
keep him from spilling Enron's dark
darkest secrets so the police did a
pretty thorough investigation as a
result of which there was many things
but material available for journalists
and then we talked to a lot of people
who went to the funeral and people who
were who were friends of cliffs in order
to piece together a piece together an
account of what happened and you said
some didn't go to the funeral from the
Enron company
Ken Lay Jeff Skilling I think Ken didn't
go to the funeral in in Houston it was
just a very strange time because it was
the wake of the company's the company's
collapse and you know the Justice
Department was descending and the FBI
was everywhere in Houston and so people
didn't people had previously been
business associates only six months ago
suddenly didn't want to be seen talking
to each other in public it's just it's
just very surreal in a way you learn in
the documentary in your book of course
the the India story a billion dollars
down the drain it's a pretty remarkable
story it's a part of this part of the
tale isn't really in the documentary
simply for time reasons but one in
central part of the Enron story was this
woman named Rebecca mark who for a while
was one of the most glamorous figures in
American business she built power plants
in remote areas of the world from
rainforests in Brazil to this plant in
India and Jeff Skilling has always
blamed Rebecca for bringing down the
company because these power plants that
were built didn't live up to the very
rosy economic assumptions that were made
about them in kind of case in point is
double you know Enron believed that
India needed the power and frankly India
probably does need the power whether
India would be able to pay for the power
and how it was an entirely different
different calculation you're saying
double double and where is that located
it's a double India
it's in the Maharashtra region of India
I believe the details are a little bit
foggy at this point so excuse me if I've
gotten that wrong and what would happen
there
well Enron built this mammoth power
plant in two and two phases but it
became a lightning rod for political
activism in India because the plants
power was going to be so expensive and
the plant was challenged in some twenty
six lawsuits all of which Enron won but
I think it wasn't it's not so much an
example of criminal wrongdoing on
Enron's part as it is just a blindness
to the to the rest of the world in this
belief we can build a power plant and
they'll pay for it because the contract
says they have to even if even if that
power was going to be incredibly
expensive and it was an example of how
Enron Enron paid people because Rebecca
mark and her team were often paid on the
projected value of power plants like
double so they'd walk away from
something like this with millions of
dollars even if the plant never made
under on a dime where is she today she's
living in Houston no indictment no no
and I think it's very difficult to argue
that Rebecca should be should be
criminally indicted in any way she
actually was forced out of Enron in
early in late 2000 and if she hadn't
been forced out she would have she would
have stayed she wasn't a quitter she
would she would never have quit and you
can falter for perhaps making bad
business decisions but a bad business
decision is different from wilfully
deceiving somebody you have an
interesting paragraph at the end of your
original story this was in March of 2001
before all this happened mm-hmm in the
end it boils down to a question of faith
quote Enron is no black box as Goldman's
Fletcher mm-hmm quote that's like
calling Michael Jordan the black box
just because you don't know what he's
going to score every quarter unquote
then again Jordan never had to promise a
hit to promise to hit a certain number
of shots in order to please investors
how much of that has changed you know
the in the end it boils down to a
question of faith is it still faith on
Wall Street I think there's a lot of
faith on Wall Street actually there are
a lot of companies where
people would rather believe then the not
believe and there's still kind of an
unwillingness to to ask questions in a
lot of cases and there's still this
focus on quarterly earnings you would
expect that obsession would have
lessened with examples like Enron and
world command Tyco and the other
corporate scandals we've had but there's
still this kind of notion that well if
you don't make your quarterly earnings
estimate then Wall Street is going to
punish your stock and people have too
much too many economic incentives tied
up and seeing the stock price go higher
now that this is a I mean all the trials
haven't been held on all that but there
have been a lot of stories about Tyco
and Delphia and lots of other
corporation what has changed for the
American if you're if you're watching
this and you you're a stock buyer is
there a checks and balances thing in
this at all I'm not sure much has
changed and I guess it's a two things
that government instituted a new law
called sarbanes-oxley that's supposed to
make corporate America behave better
sarbanes-oxley has become pretty
controversial with companies saying it
goes too far and it imposes too many
costs on our system and you know to me
the issue with sarbanes-oxley isn't
whether it imposes too many costs or not
it's that it's more rules and in the end
a company like Enron was all about using
the rules about twisting them about sort
of using the rules as a roadmap of the
possible I don't think more rules are
usually the answer a company that wants
to follow the letter of the law while
violating the spirit of the law can
often find a way to do it the question
is a deeper ethical one I think on a on
a brighter note I think you know no
accounting firm wants to be Arthur
Andersen and runs accounts which were
taken down by the Enron scandal no Board
of Directors wants to be on Ron's board
of directors who are you know who
suffered a great deal of shame for their
for their for their role in the Enron
affair no executive wants to be Ken Lay
now facing a criminal trial so I think
fear is a pretty effective counterweight
to greed but there's a reason at the end
of every bull market in American history
we've had a couple of great scandals and
I think there's a reason that that that
that tends to happen people's greed gets
ahead of them and I don't I don't I
think to say that things are different
now or that things have changed
permanently
in the snake that that in the system and
Justice Department the SEC the press the
analysts the conference calls the Board
of Directors the audit committees the
banks all that where is the best
possible protection in that what do you
trust the most and all that to do it
right oh Lord I actually have a lot of
faith honestly in the role of outsiders
the people who aren't part of the system
I think that for example short-sellers
play a really important role in in in
policing our market if you will and
people say well they're biased - they
want to stock to go down yeah they are
but they're biased in the opposite
direction and short sellers often do
really careful homework on a company and
there's a reason that short sellers were
early to spot problems at Enron Oh Tyco
at Adelphia at worldcom at other
companies because they're looking
they're looking for problems and I think
in a market you need people to have
incentives on both sides of the table so
that people will do their homework if
everybody wants a stock to go up
everybody's going to be blinded by greed
and nobody's gonna look too carefully
last question what do you think you'll
be done in ten years you know I never
know how to answer that because if you
had asked me ten years ago would I've
written a book about Enron that was made
into a documentary I would have said I
don't even know if I would have said I
would be a journalist too so I just I
just don't know hopefully something
interesting